Welcome, everybody. Welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today is March 1st, which means
it is the start
of Women's History Month.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Exactly right. Yeah.
Just remember --
behind every great woman
is a man loudly repeating
her ideas.
Let's get to some news.
Today, in Washington,
the Conservative Political
Action Conference, or CPAC,
kicked off.
It's basically Coachella
for people who post on Facebook
in all caps.
I heard that this year
top Republicans
like Ron DeSantis
and Mitch McConnell
aren't attending CPAC.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
Yeah.
It's being held in D.C.
at the Gaylord National Resort
and Convention Center.
Now --
[ Laughter ]
Now we know Mike Pence
won't be there, either.
I don't think...
CPAC calls itself the largest
and most influential
gathering of conservatives
in the world.
The speeches will be serious,
while the people trying to dance
at the after-party
will be hilarious.
♪♪
But this is nice.
After each speech,
there will be a QAnon.
Uh, sorry. Q&A. Q&A.
After --
There'll be a Q&A.
Did you guys hear about this?
A few days ago,
when First Lady Jill Biden
was flying back
from a trip to Kenya,
the plane stopped to refuel
in Italy,
and she ordered 19 pizzas.
-Man!
-So, apparently, weed is legal
on "Air Force One."
I -- That's interesting.
She was gonna order 20 pizzas,
but she didn't want
to overdo it, yeah.
Then she needed beer,
so they stopped in Germany.
[ Laughter ]
People are talking about this.
Apparently, King Charles
is evicting Harry and Meghan
from their royal residence
in the U.K.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
It's a tough break
for Harry and Meghan.
Nothing hurts more
than getting evicted
three years after you move out.
You know what I'm saying?
Some TV news.
Today, the third season of
"The Mandalorian" premiered.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, uh -- Yeah. Love that.
You can tell Baby Yoda's
gotten super famous because
in this one he just keeps
plugging his tequila brand.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The new season of
"The Mandalorian" is here.
That's right. Fans have been
waiting over two years.
And as a special treat,
Disney Plus announced
a new spinoff series.
-Oh.
-Yeah. Check this out. Yeah.
-Stay tuned
after "The Mandalorian"
for the all-new spinoff...
"Cocaine Baby Yoda."
-He-he-he!
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
-I'll watch it.
Well, get this.
Today, Netflix said
that later this year
they're premiering
a "Stranger Things" play.
Right now, a team of
choreographers is hard at work
teaching a Demogorgon
how to jazz-hands.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It's an interesting play.
After every ten minutes,
an actor asks,
"Are you still watching?"
Hey, I saw that the release of
"The Super Mario Brothers Movie"
had been moved up by two days.
-Oh.
-In other words, yeah,
the film's producers heard...
[ Mario coin jingles ]
And they realized
it could be a...
[ Mario 1-Up sound ]
So they took
Mario's release date and...
[ Mario power-up sound ]
Which means the other movies
that come out that week are...
[ "Mario dies" sound effect ]
[ Applause ]
Well, listen to this.
Busch Gardens in Tampa
just opened
one of the world's tallest
and fastest rides.
Can we see it?
-Ooh.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
-Looks like how
my daughter draws me.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's called
the Serengeti Flyer.
You may know it
by its other name,
The Cellphone Catapult.
It's like --
"Oh, why didn't I...?"
I'm not sure I trust the world's
fastest ride at Busch Gardens.
It's like hearing the world's
fastest car is built by Kia.
You go, "Well..."
And finally, do you
ever see a photo in the news
and think the headline
should be different?
Well, I'll show you. We'll
take care of that right now.
It's time for
"News & Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News and improved ♪
-The headline could be better.
-Sure.
-Let me give you an example.
This first photo here.
The original headline was...
That headline can
definitely be improved.
Because if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
-Aww.
[ Applause ]
-Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
It's like, "Oh. Sorry!
I didn't see anything."
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm gonna go see 'Avatar.'"
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"No specials because
everything here is a special?"
[ Laughs hysterically ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
-Oh. Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"Oh! Curry, over here!
Steph, Steph! Right here, man!"
[ Applause ]
And, finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...